taxer les plus riches pour alléger la
dette et faire face aux coronavirus si
la france se montre réticente sur ce
sujet sensible d'autres pays étudient
déjà l'option une option qui
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
croire à vient des riches eux mêmes une
poussée d'altruisme dans un monde malade
comme une façon de se rendre utile et
d'apporter sa pierre à l'édifice dans
une lettre ouverte baptisé millionnaire
for humanity plus d'une centaine de
millionnaires on demandait à être taxés
immédiatement et de manière permanente
nous ne sommes pas ceux qui soignent les
malades dans les unités de soins
intensifs
nous ne conduisons pas les ambulances
qui amène les malades à l'hôpital
nous ne sommes pas ceux qui regardent
nice les rayons des épiceries ou qui
délivre de la nourriture de porte à
porte les problèmes causés et révélé par
le coït 19 ne peuvent être résolus par
la charité
les chefs de gouvernement doivent
prendre la responsabilité de lever les
fonds via une augmentation permanente
des taxes sur les plus fortunés de la
planète des gens comme nous depuis des
années des milliardaires tels que warren
buffet ou encore bill gates demande à
être taxés davantage un appel qui semble
avoir été entendu et notamment pas là
webtaxes commisssion au royaume uni ceux
ci ont rendu un rapport au début du mois
de décembre qui démontre qu'en taxant
les plus riches
pendant cinq ans le gouvernement
pourrait récolter 260 milliards de
livres soit plus de 280 milliards
d'euros une option sérieusement
envisagée par le royaume uni pour faire
écho à l'argentine qui n'a pas hésité à
mettre en place une taxe exceptionnelle
pour faire face à la crise c'est ainsi
qu'au pays de maradona et de messi 12000
argentin parmi les plus aisés du pays
ont été mis à contribution pour
permettre à l'état de financer les aides
sociales
les subventions aux pme mais également
les programmes d'exploitation gazière
dans ce pays miné par une crise sans
précédent l'état espère récolter plus de
3 milliards d'euros pour limiter les
effets de la pandémie
alors que certains représentants du
monde des affaires dénonce une politique
confiscatoire et une pression fiscale
d'autres applaudissent décision en
précisant que l'impact réel sur les
grandes fortunes sera très peu
conséquent ces personnes disposent en
moyenne de liquidités 25 fois plus élevé
que le montant qui va leur être prélevés
c'est une taxe qui cherche à encourager
le rat
patry mende actifs détenus à l'étranger
et à stimuler les investissements en
argentine et si le cas argentin allait
servir d'exemple au reste de la planète
c'est en tout cas une initiative saluée
par le fonds monétaire international
celui là même qui avait mis à genoux
l'argentine dans les années 2000
l'institution internationale a récemment
appelé les gouvernements envisagé de
taxer davantage les ménages les plus
riches et les entreprises n'est plus
lucratives
les gouvernements devraient envisager
des impôts plus élevés pour les ménages
les plus aisés et les entreprises très
rentable ces revenus supplémentaires
contribuerait à payer des services
essentiels comme la santé et les filets
de sécurité sociale pendant une crise
qui touche de manière disproportionnée
les plus pauvres de la société alors que
dans l'hexagone la pandémie de qu'ovide
a fait exploser la pauvreté et que le
plan de relance du gouvernement ne
semble pas connaître de limites
la nécessité s'impose de trouver au plus
vite de l'argent alors comment et sous
quelle forme
une taxe spéciale sur les fortunes au
profit des plus pauvres
l'acteur français vincent lindon l'a
déjà proposé une taxe baptisée jean
valjean qui proposait déjà de taxer les
riches pour soulager les pauvres
belle initiative mais très vite oublié
organiser un come back de l' isf la bête
noire des fortunes de france
inenvisageable pour bercy et pourtant
l'étau semble se resserrer sur le
gouvernement alors qu'une troisième
vague pourrait se dessiner avec une
dette qui explose atteignant 116 4 % du
pib fin septembre soit 2600 74 milliards
d'euros la france n'a jamais été aussi
endetté depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale une crise historique qui
pourrait pousser le gouvernement à
revoir sa feuille de route est peut-être
envisager de faire comme l'argentine
taxer les riches pour payer la crise